the Loki season 2 finale was incredible
it was the conclusion at least so far of
the 14-year Journey that Tom Heston has
had with Loki now we've heard he is
coming back and we believe that he is
coming back again in Avengers Secret
Wars however somebody else's future in
the MCU right now is a big question mark
and that is Kang the Conqueror slth
actor who plays him Jonathan major
Jonathan major returned in Loki season 2
as not only he who remains but also
Victor timely as well and of course we
saw him as the king the Conqueror in
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania he is
set to be the big bad villain of the
Multiverse Saga however we have heard
recently that might not be the case
anymore and that Jonathan majors and the
character Kang the Conqueror and any
other Kang variant might be out of the
MCU as the big bat and in fact Avengers
King Dynasty might not even be Avengers
King Dynasty anymore you might have
heard not too long ago that Marvel
Studios got rid of the writer for Kang
Dynasty Jeff lovess and today we have a
new report stating that the reason this
happened is because there is no longer a
focus on King the Conqueror now some of
you may be asking well how is that even
possible they set him up to be the big
bad especially in that post-credit scene
from Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania
and yes that is true but unfortunately
things can change and since Jonathan
major has been going through quite a lot
recently Marvel Studios unfortunately
had to decide which Direction they're
going to go with not only Jonathan
majors and King the Conqueror but the
MCU in general and it would be kind of
weird to write King out of the MCU but
it is also entirely possible and this
does make it possible and opens up
Marvel Studios to bring in Victor Von
Doom AKA Dr Doom as the main villain of
the Multiverse Saga this was actually
reported recently in an article from
variety and actually they specifically
mentioned in that article that Marvel
Studios was thinking about how to move
forward without Kang being the villain
and one of the answers to that that
Marvel Studios had thought of themselves
was to replace him with Dr Doom now if
you're not aware of the situation
Jonathan major right now the actor who
plays King the Conqueror Victor timley
he who remains all of the king variants
is currently going through trial for
cases against him for assault he is
facing up to one year in prison if he is
found guilty this has put Marvel Studios
in quite a predicament and is quite
complicated because Jonathan major and
his legal team from the very beginning
have stated that he is innocent and is
in fact the victim and that he was
assaulted and they claim that they have
substantial evidence to prove this so
Marvel Studios was kind of playing the
waiting game and kudos to them for not
just firing him automatically when these
claims came out against him but
unfortunately it looks like they might
be moving away from Kang in general
despite what happens in this trial
today's report is coming from Joanna
Robinson many of you might have heard
her name recently as she is one of the
authors of MCU the reign of Marvel
Studios the book has caught a lot of
attention and it's a great book if you
haven't read it or listened to it yet I
do recommend it and especially if you
want to know the history of Marvel
Studios it's really great on that the
authors of that book including Joanna
Robinson interviewed over a hundred
different people who worked with or
around Marvel Studios they spilled a lot
of tea talked about a lot of the inside
stuff that goes on and today on the
podcast that she co-hosts the ringer
verse she said that A source told her
that Jeff lovess who was the writer for
Kang Dynasty who also wrote Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum Mania was removed from
King Dynasty because the entire King
story was being scrapped so if this is
true that means no more King which means
Avengers King Dynasty is no longer going
to be called Avengers King Dynasty so
will refer to it as Avengers 5 although
keep in mind and note this is not 100%
confirmed this is just something that
she said a source has told her and keep
in mind this is simply an option for
Marvel Studios to do they might have
already begun to go down this route but
it's still an option because I would
like to think that if Jonathan major is
found innocent they would keep him as
king the Conqueror but here's the deal
originally Marvel Studios did not plan
on King the Conqueror being the main
villain of the Multiverse Saga what
happened was when they saw Jonathan
Major's portrayal of he who remains and
then Kang in Quantum Mania they decided
that it was so good that they should
make Kang the main villain of the multif
for Saga which makes sense considering
his comic origin of traveling through
space and time and mastering it but it
wasn't their original plan and now we're
wondering well was Dr Doom the original
main villain of the Multiverse Saga
especially if you consider the fact that
Marvel Studios seem to always know that
the Multiverse Saga was going to lead up
to Avengers Secret Wars and in both
issues in the comics Dr Doom is the main
villain and since Marvel Studios going
into the Multiverse Saga had the rights
and currently have the rights to use Dr
Doom in the MCU along with a fantastic
for perhaps that was their plan
especially if you consider when when
they revealed phase 4 at San Diego
ComicCon the last thing Kevin said
was we didn't even have a chance to talk
about the Fantastic 4 so clearly since
then Kevin VY had plans for the
Fantastic 4 characters and of course one
of the main Fantastic 4 characters is Dr
Doom so maybe that's their plan going
forward but how exactly will they write
out Kang the Conqueror well kind of
fortunately but unfortunately the lowkey
season finale actually set it up for
Kang to kind of go away so getting rid
of Kang and bringing Doom in or another
Main villain isn't actually that hard
and we'll explain how they do it but
first big thank you to Highland titles
for sponsoring this video before we leap
back into the world of superpowers got
something truly extraordinary for our
Noble listeners imagine that you yes you
can become a lord or lady for just $30
buying a plot of land from Highland
tile.com will allow you to make use of a
Scottish tradition in which land owners
are given a courtesy title with more
than 15,000 five-star reviews the
Highland titles gift pack is an
incredibly popular gift and the Highland
titles app available from the app and
play stores is a new addition that
allows you to explore a 3D replica of
the land choose the location of your
plot and decorate it using augmented
reality embrace the Majesty as every
purchase helps to conserve the all
inspiring heroic beauty of the Scottish
Wilderness you can soar into the world
of nobility My Friends by visiting
Highland ties.com and become a lord or
lady today use the discount code Cosmic
to receive 25% off your order that's
Highland tile.com and use code Cosmic so
the way the Loki finale left everything
off was Loki allowing the Multiverse to
truly have free will but that meant Kang
variants are going to pop up however the
TVA now has a new job and they only have
one job monitor every single timeline
every single Universe not for Nexus
events or anything that may set the
timeline in a different direction but
monitor them for Kang variants or as
they refer to K as he who remains but of
course they're all Kang now that's the
tva's only job now and it could go
either way they could keep Jonathan
magus's King and continue on with
Avengers King Dynasty that would be epic
but if they decide to go a different
route all they would have to do is say
the TVA takes care of Kings they wipe
them all out so they're not a threat
they can't cause the multiversal war
because the TVA gets to them before they
do anything that really is quite simple
however this opens it up for another
villain who is a genius and Dr Doom is
one of the smartest characters in the
entire MCU it opens it up for him to
make his MCU debut as the main villain
who could go on to control space and
time in fact they could even make it to
where he somehow gets his hands on King
Technology and what's extremely
interesting is that in the comics Kang
and Dr Doom actually run into each other
we see a Time displaced Kang run into Dr
Doom where they both believe that they
are actually related to each other they
believe Kang is a distant ancestor of Dr
Doom and from there on out Kang actually
remodels his armor to look like Dooms
and then he goes by the Scarlet
Centurion we saw a version of the
Scarlet Centurion in the post credit
scene for Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania he was a part of the Kang Trio
with a mortise and ramut now doing this
like I mentioned would also open up
Avengers Secret Wars to be more comic
accurate to where Dr Doom was actually
the villain and before we heard rumors
that the ultimate King villain in secret
Wars was going to be a king variant who
was also the beyonder he was still King
but was the beyonder at the same time
well in the comics and Secret Wars Dr
Doom manages to take the power of the
beyonder and becomes God Emperor doom
and rules everything so they could still
do that storyline except kind of get rid
of Kang and simply just have the
beyonder come into play then we would
get God Emperor Doom this really isn't
that hard to do and it seems like Marvel
Studios has realized that and if they do
decide to go a different route than Kang
the Conqueror this is a pretty great
option to go down however keep in mind
this is a report from somebody who is is
not a part of Marvel Studios but who has
heard this from a source so this is not
100% confirmed but even without this
report we could assume that Marvel
Studios was considering going a
different direction because variety said
it in their article as well I think
ultimately it will depend on whether or
not Jonathan major is found guilty or
innocent I think if he's innocent they
continue on with him in the MCU and Kang
stays but if he's guilty they move on
they either recast him or they move away
from Kang all together and probably
bring in Dr Doom but go ahead and let me
know what you think about this would it
be cool if they decided to not go the
king route to bring in Dr Doom let us
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on the MCU and if you
subscribe and leave a comment below
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick one winner at the
end of each month you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and is
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof